the Joe Rogan experience there's a I
don't know I mean look at me I
definitely get nervous sometimes and
people overall everyone always like
accused me I do it much [ __ ] to my face
I'm like no you'll know I'll look like a
[ __ ] moon bounce like I already know
I'm gonna do it eventually yes for sure
why do people accuse you of it because
you don't look like thank you very thin
nose though people would worry that you
did you knows it's wild because you'd
think I got my nose done but my nostrils
are crooked I went to a doctor in
Beverly Hills because I had sinus
problems for a longest time and he
actually said you know I I can you have
a septic what does it deviated you so
it's like you have a deviated septum and
I was like what do you do like he was
like we can get a nose job
yeah totally and I never did it because
but your nose is thin thank you
if he did it what would he do make it
fake nostrils equal even they're really
asymmetrical and it's like problematic
and sometimes in its problem when I do
something in television sometimes they
have to fix my nostrils host to make it
even [ __ ] about your not just
distracting I feel like those things are
there just to find out who's really
weird like if you're really freaking out
about someone's asymmetrical nostrils
it's just I mean the key to most movie
stars into is they're symmetrical you
know they're just like mmm you know
think about the most beautiful women on
the world have some symmetry but yeah I
don't it's wild I mean I have I mean I
talk about in my special I have had
surgery on my boobs I did have boobs
done Hollow which is kind of this might
interest you
the eye I was learning because I had all
kinds of [ __ ] and the way that they make
boobs look good is because I think I
heard you talking about someone about
the shitty old breast implants and the
way they make them good now is that they
put you on like a crucifix oak and they
do the surgery while you're standing up
what so that they so you're out cold yes
so that they fall well I know my job
really
oh so I finally went through a guy that
knew how to do that yeah it's my [ __ ]
mild but so I admit what I have you know
but on my face it is alarming because it
does feel like female comedians a couple
of famous ones that we know in they age
went down that round I don't know if
it's like the same thing that got you
into comedy is the same thing that made
you think you had to do
you know I've read a lot of stuff about
like childhood sexual abuse ago people
go really off the grid with their face
that's like a type of dysmorphia or a
lot of people a lot of psychologists
have said because I've talked to a
therapist whose job is in dysmorphia to
advise on whether another surgery should
be done by somebody like if they're
getting dysmorphic and a lot of times
it's if you've had childhood sexual
abuse you want to change your face so
that it's not you don't see the person
in the mirror that got it right like
it's the Michael Jackson thing yeah yeah
it's like a childhood trauma yeah yeah
the Michael Jackson thing was always
that he hated his father and he hated
looking at his father in his own face so
when it's that extreme I try to like not
judge because I'm like oh there might be
some psychological [ __ ] that I don't
know about for sure you know but it's
getting worse and worse with this
Instagram [ __ ] because the kids are
grown I mean it used to be like we had
acne and we'd go to school with acne you
know but now it's like you're projecting
this flawless perfect face and then you
have to show up to school with [ __ ]
acne the next day like also it's like
people want their face to actually look
like an Instagram filter which is
bananas bananas photos it doesn't but
again it's a test to see who's [ __ ] up
like who wants that not not girl who
wants that as far as guy like what guy
wants that it's I'm so confounded by
what I'm seeing right like okay also you
just want to look like everybody else
when you're young well the weird thing
is women wanted to be super skinny
that's a weird one I think that's always
been around no lots of models skinny
things yeah it's not it's not attractive
to men
yeah like men like asses yeah I mean
everyone's different right yeah I like
girls with meat mm-hmm well cuz that
also translates to fertility I mean it's
like we want someone that looks for sure
and you know healthy yeah well I want to
grow and carry couch with me for real do
you want a girl you pick up the end of
the couch now let's move over here I
can't expect you to pick up the whole
couch under the couch pull your weight
it's gonna be harder for you than me but
we don't have to carry that far
[Applause]